there's a lot going on in the new
trailer for spider-man far from home
including one big reveal about the state
of the MCU in the wake of Avengers
endgame but with an illusionist like
Mysterio in the mix or might not be as
it appears now that we've seen the
trailer here are some small details you
may have missed and by the way big
spoilers for endgame ahead you've been
one for a brief moment in the trailer we
see Peter Parker rocking a very familiar
looking pair of sunglasses that's right
those are Tony Stark's our signature
shades while it's not very clear what
he's doing with them he seems to have a
pretty short expression on his face
after looking through them that may have
something to do with the fact that those
sunglasses are a bit more than a gift
from a fallen friend they're probably
filled if Starks immature nanotech in
Avengers infinity war we see stock put
those glasses on shortly after colored
Cydia and ebony more appear on earth
when he does he starts talking to his AI
assistant Friday which seems to indicate
that they provide a direct link to stark
technology even without wearing an Iron
Man suit shortly afterward when stark
activates his nanotech to turn into Iron
Man he takes off his glasses and they
seem to actually disappear in his hand
so are the glasses an advanced piece of
stock nano technology that helps Peter
and his fight in far from home or are
they simply a bold fashion statement
that will earn him lots of mercury from
his friends only time will tell
sub dickwad Marvel has a history of
altering trailer footage to feed the
hype machine like including Hulk at the
Battle of Wakanda in the Infinity war
spots or leaving a ton of it on the
cutting room floor like Black Widow
getting her aggression out of the firing
range in his endgame trailers the latest
spider-man far from home trailer is no
exception
with a sneaky spider suit switcheroo
happening between the teaser trailer and
the official trailer in the teaser
trailer Peter is seen sporting his
homecoming arrow suit while making his
appearance advance may at the Salvation
Army's homeless support event in NYC
your friendly neighborhood spider-man is
still outfitted in the iconic red and
blue back stage - a mask when he's
caught in the middle of May and harpies
flirt session but in the latest official
trailer Peter is wearing his iron spider
suit at the event meaning the teaser
trailer clips were either shot twice or
there's some seamless CGI in play we
noticed the same location because of the
recessed lights above the kitchen prep
area in the background so what gives
well the iron spider suit has more
significance to Peter now that the suits
designer one's reluctant father figure
Tony
Stark has passed on it's just
speculation but Marvel also probably
didn't want to blatantly spoil Peters
fate an endgame by showing him alive and
well wearing the same suit he
disintegrated in at the end of infinity
war regardless this Loki level trickery
is yet another example of Marvel going
to great lengths to hide the details of
his MCU blockbusters in advance of
opening day
if the spider-man origin you remember is
the one from the first of Sam Raimi
directed spider-man you don't remember
crusher Hogan you remember Macho Man
Randy Savage as bone saw McGraw who's
likely got that name because Savage
would never have played a character
named Hogan too much bad blood between
him and the holster but the wrestler
Peter Parker originally took on in the
comics when he was looking for fame was
indeed named crusher Hogan and if you
look closely behind happy Hogan no
relation you can see a poster
advertising crushes original offer 100
dollars to anyone who can stay in the
ring with him for three minutes there's
also a little bell there so maybe this
is the building where he issued the
challenge we never saw the full origin
of Tom Hollands spider-man but it's
entirely possible to believe he took on
and be crusher prior to the
life-changing night his Uncle Ben died
in July 2018 a deadline reported that
Turkish actor new manager had taken on
the role of Dmitry in spider-man far
from home the report further theorized
that he may be playing dmitriy smirnov a
half-brother of Kraven the hunter known
better to spider-man fans as chameleon
he's one of spider-man's oldest Rhodes
appearing all the way back an amazing
spider-man issue one is he in the
trailer it's hard to say but there are
lots of places he could be given that
chameleons whole deal is that you can
look like anyone just like mystique in
the x-men movies one of the criminal
spider-man apprehends and the fancy
ballroom early on in the trailer is
wearing what looks like leopard print
pajamas this may be an early Demetri
appearance wearing something similar to
what his fur loving relative with sports
or he could be throughout the rest of
the trailer looking like just about
anyone we have to assume Mysterio is up
to no good
could the Nick Fury or Maria hill
spider-man meets in Italy be chameleons
in disguise working on Mysterio's behalf
in some huge ruse
they definitely have a lot of reasons in
their back pocket as to why only
spider-man can do this job or heck he
may be MJ I mean it's kind of obvious
while the impacts of pizza and countless
others missing out on five years of life
are still up in the air one thing in the
second far from home trail
pretty clear this new revived world is
nothing but love for Ironman the trailer
starts with Peter looking at the giant
mural of the fallen hero on the side of
a building in New York City but that's
far from the only tribute that Tony gets
in addition to a memorial that appears
to be somewhere in Europe viewers can
also see many drawings of Iron Man in
the background of an art class at
Peter's school showing that the world
Post ends game recognizes that it owes
everything or well half of everything to
the one the only invincible Iron Man
Tony was a huge part of Peters origin
story in the MCU and even in death he
still looms large over Peters day-to-day
world whether he's out doing hero things
or just trying to finish high school
after five weird years away towards the
end of the trailer Peter can be seen
with a Spiderman styled hologram over
his rest he reacts to the device for
some surprise looking off screen to
catch somebody's eye the way the trailer
is edited it appears he's looking at
happy Hogan
it isn't clear where they are but they
seem to be surrounded by some relatively
high-tech decor maybe on board happy
sick looking jet it seems possible that
Tony's left at least one more surprise
behind for Peter with the rest tech
seeming to harken back to a similar
physical bracelet Peter showed off
journey and credits finger of Captain
America Civil War alternatively this
could be some sort of device from the
mysterious Quinton back who's been known
in the comics to use technology and
delusions to present the appearance of
superpowers the only thing we can tell
from Pete's expression is he's surprised
good surprise too bad surprised
we'll find out soon check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]